but I've noticed this trends of average
women getting exceptional outcomes not
only in the media
um and partially partially I do think
this is whole flation because again you
know 100 years ago pretty much all the
guys got a virgin so by you know 2023 if
you're not a virgin you would have been
a hall 100 years ago I don't make the
rules right I know that's not the same
definition in modern times but if we're
gonna go from a historical point of view
it is very unusual to be in a time
period where the women are not virgins
again like I do think that men have to
work 10 times harder for a chick that's
a lot more average than their
grandfathers and their
great-grandfathers would have gotten so
and I see this trend continue in
Hollywood where average chicks are
getting exceptional outcomes and you
know I I noticed this because I was
thinking that I haven't seen a Megan Fox
level of hot chicken forever and I was
thinking of how you know women with
acting careers used to kind of stop at
like 30 maybe 35 they would make it to
but I've noticed that like women like
Sandra Bullock Jennifer Aniston are
still getting booked for really really
big roles you know recently we had a
Barbie movie and all of Twitter was set
Ablaze because everyone was arguing if
Margot Robbie was hot or if she was mid
and you know I gotta be honest Margot
Robbie was definitely a Barbie level of
hot at 22 but at 32 you know I think you
could go to any college campus and find
chicks better looking I think I've had
chicks better looking out on the show
you know I don't think it's that
uncommon but it's interesting because
you it used to be that in Hollywood to
be an A-list celebrity you had to be a
certain level of good looking and I've
just seen this trend you know really
change so I want to first show you guys
the hot celebrities of you know like 10
15 years ago so here we got Megan Fox
right oh
beautiful I know she's like crazy now
but I'm sorry this chick is is stunning
okay the next one
now we have Mila Jovovich
again
stunning right I don't think anyone
would really discount but that's at
least an eight or higher okay
Halle Berry you know I'm I'm not a fan
of the short hair I really don't believe
women should have short hair but she can
pull it off why
she's an eight or higher and the way I I
do a similar scale to Kevin Samuels
where you know four to six is like
average normal looking
sevens don't really exist we don't
really rate people sevens
um eights or higher
is like Hollywood you know traditional
modeling contracts not not what they
have today now we got Sierra you know
this is one of the number one women
that I get on the show and it's
interesting because what I would ask men
celebrity crushes I just noticed a trend
of guys only naming celebrity crushes
from 10 15 20 years ago and I would
never hear guys mention any Chick
from today not really okay so now we
have the celebrities of today and I
would rate most of these chicks
adjustable sixes I would say they're all
above average they're all cute
none of them are these stunningly
beautiful women we had of 10 20 years
ago they're not Jennifer Aniston they're
not Angelina Jolie now we have Jenna
ortiga again like cute right but
is she Megan Fox level
I I would say no okay I'm not a guy so I
want all the guys to let me know in the
comments Jenna Ortega I would maybe put
her seven seven okay
now we have our favorite actress
she looks exactly like the last chick to
me they look
literally exactly the same we have the
Snow White Star very you know humble
check right there
um but again these are like 18 19 20
year olds being told they're like the
next hottest thing when really they're
just kind of
average chicks and what seemed to be
like propped up nowadays so that was
that's Rachel zegler again I'd give her
six you know strong six and this is
Millie Bobby Brown and Millie Bobby
Brown is like the number one actress
right now
um like out of all these chicks I I know
her the most and she's really good she's
actually so talented but again
six six yeah cute right definitely cute
none of them ugly but it's like
you know I kind of miss watching TV and
feeling bad about myself and I feel like
Hollywood has taken this away from me
you know I used to open a magazine and I
would see women Megan Fox Angelina Jolie
and I would just leave
feeling a little bad I'm like damn I'll
never look like that but you know you
still appreciate the beauty you it's
like so you know I would go to a
basketball game or a volleyball game and
I would feel a little bad you know and I
really feel like
Hollywood has taken away the hierarchy
of beauty we used to reward the most
beautiful people and that was the
standard to be in Hollywood but for
whatever reason
um I really just think Hollywood doesn't
want to appeal to the male gays anymore
they want to appeal to the female gays
and therefore they're going to do less
attractive women you know so us chicks
don't feel bad but I say no no we are
supposed to see the best of the best
it's like when you go to the Olympics
you don't go there to see average people
play sports when we go to Hollywood when
we go to
when we open a magazine when I see a
model I I want to be inspired I wanna I
wanna be able to pull off the off the
magazine and like put it on my fridge so
I eat less
I really just think that the people in
charge you know
they want us stupid that way we are easy
to control and when women are by
ourselves which we really are
in this economy like we really are more
and more now that we have more single
women than ever more divorced women than
ever and just women as a whole we have
more power than ever you know
um they can just run a couple ads and
convince us that average chicks can date
these crazy above average guys and you
know what I noticed I noticed too and a
lot of like the romance movies nowadays
like you know women we loved 50 Shades
of Gray
and what is that it's an average six of
a chick cute chick
dating a guy that's like a
multi-billionaire and they go off and
they live happily ever after like at
least before
with Snow White and like you know
Cinderella you knew you couldn't have
those outcomes unless you were really
really hot okay that was like the
standard like okay ladies you can maybe
ride off into the sunset with a prince
if you're really hot but now social
media has us all convinced that we're
just eights nines and tens and you see
girls in the media you know that are
convinced they're eights nines and
eights nines and tens and you convince
average chicks that we can just have
these crazy outcomes and it's so funny
because I just think in the old
generation you would see like TMZ and
you would see all of these celebrities
but you knew it wasn't real life but
because us chicks you know have access
to these guys we would never in a
million years have access to it makes us
live like
not you know real lives until we hit
like 35 and you know everything crashes
down
but you never know they could just take
away women's right to vote and this
whole thing would be done